did you know that Darth Vader the evil
Sith Lord is running for president of
the Ukraine but don't take my word for
it we've got video proof
okay he's got my vote all right so this
is actually only partially a joke
so Darth Vader this guy did run in 2012
he was not on the ballot but he got 3%
of the write-ins which is completely
insane they threw that out because they
don't even count their items but he did
get 3% that's a pretty decent percentage
for a Sith Lord what are some of his
political actions let's find out in 2013
he was carried in a sedan chair by a
group of Imperial Stormtroopers to
Odessa City Hall declaring himself
acting mayor of the city
citing an order by Emperor Palpatine and
as I said he scored a record 3% of the
vote in 2012 parliamentary election and
the votes were never registered because
they were writings which rendered them
void under Ukrainian law but he actually
this actually is becoming something he's
running on the Ukrainian Internet party
and oh and you love this so to run you
have to get you have to raise two
hundred and thirty six thousand dollars
the party has already done that for him
so yes this is obviously a joke and we
can be joking about it but he's actually
doing this too so is this sort of what
we needed till I get a little sense out
of the Ukraine thing because everybody's
talking about it here nobody sure what's
going on can Star Wars give us a little
momentary oh yeah this is the greatest
thing that's ever happened to politics I
mean I want to like you know raise some
money and then you know your big Golden
Girls fan will he'll you know try to run
for election as her favorite golden girl
I mean there's so many for Betty White
oh my god I would tell a secretary I
wrote for all of them uh yeah you know I
think it's it's it's absolutely it's so
absurd I mean Putin is so absurd the
whole situation is so absurd so why not
have Darth Vader it's amazing how James
Earl Jones can throw his voice like that
really really I mean the guy's voice was
was pretty good speaks Ukrainian or
Russian what would that be
like I think it was mafia know I know do
you think Putin actually envies this guy
look he pooed and sort of would like to
rule like Darth Vader if Putin is a
badass he just crushes people well I
think that he probably saw this and he's
like you would destroy Darth Vader for
you know like he's even more evil yeah
which actually made me think like the
guy like it would it would be
interesting if they got like a Mark
Hamill look-alike I said Luke Skywalker
is running then there's like the good
that could be kind of fun drawn to the
dark side though right if you were gonna
vote for one or the other
you'd probably vote darkside with the
raw darks I mean the whole Bush
administration access to evil came it
was all it was all it was all Star Wars
III honestly think that's how they
explained it to George Bush that like
I'm serious I honestly think that they
were like this okay Saddam Hussein is
like Darth Vader well in Revenge of the
Sith you know there was the big line
that Bush said about you're either with
us or against us and Revenge of the Sith
which came out after that they said it I
mean Anakin Skywalker says it to obi-wan
Kenobi and then you're either with me or
you're you're my enemies Falls with you
know he's like are you still playing
with your puppets captain all right yeah
no that's things it's just no is Darth
Vader is this like a third party or is
it see it's the Ukrainian Internet party
but I mean they're actually raising the
money do we need a little of this in our
political system it's such a mess here
do we need some like joke like either a
comedian to run or something crazy like
this to really we've had well we've had
what's-his-name in a minute with that Al
Franken in Minnesota and
are you pass away now Gary Coleman ran
for something yes he can witness that
was this whole thing really talking
about the point one percent do we need
like something like that to shake of our
system it's so broken right it's so
interesting to be because like the
situation Ukraine is so tenuous and it's
so it's really like we haven't seen this
type of like aggression in a long time
you know we've seen the aggression
between like you know you know nor I was
just about to say North and South Dakota
at North Dakotans let their people leave
I like at you tap my's when you said
that like you're from North Dakota but
you know you know a country like taking
of just flat out like oh I'm gonna take
this land and they you better be careful
we're gonna put you know our guards on
your border and stuff so it's so serious
and it's so like oh my god what's gonna
happen day to day that it's a little bit
surprising to me that there is a Darth
Vader like oh and hey listen I got it
you know and we also have Darth Vader so
these are kind of inspiring though it
seemed like a great day I think it's
great I think Darth Vader should be in
every election yeah and yeah I really do
should run in every country he should
run it oh my god yes yeah you know how
many people honest to god you know how
many Americans would raise money and
would vote they would they would totally
they're so sick of both parties yeah
they're so if you if you had maybe like
not a Darth Vader but you if you had
like an American folk hero right like I
don't know like someone's like a little
bit more positive than Darth Vader
American folk Harrison no listen I ran
for eighth grade representative in
junior high school and I was the only
one running there was no so I had to win
I had to win I was gonna win yeah and I
got all the votes except one person had
to write it and they wrote in Donald
Duck so I think if Donald Duck ran
somebody like that good I'm telling you
they would raise a lot of money and they
would get really far because people are
so sick of what
happening in like Congress they're so
sick of both parties like if someone
yeah Donald grant yeah I believe the
final thought on this what do you think
George Lucas thinks when he sees this
stuff like he just had this idea around
1974 this little space idea and it
became this thing that is so beyond
bonkers huge culturally and now
politically you think he watches his
stuff and he's like this is some crazy
[ __ ] oh it's great I mean of course can
you think I mean like you know if if you
ever have you know you do TV show or you
do a stand-up thing or you're on the
show somebody runs up to and goes I saw
you in you know thank you very much you
know I mean can you imagine this is the
level that this guy these characters run
a running for the I mean that's crazy
yeah right he created a character they
wanted to rule the universe and now he
has a guy actually running yeah well how
about Superman Superman could run for
president of the United States I mean
people love Superman I think I think
anyone I mean that's what if you did it
like American Idol style yeah you can
end up with the wrong people I'm saying
like is if you get the right people
voting the wrong people anyway yeah yeah
I mean a Christina Aguilera could be
running the country because someone
could be like voting well we need a lady
there you go I don't know about her but
Christina Aguilera 2016 there you go oh
good god